last as I can't find
anybody seen my glasses please go on
today we are gathered here today with
the purpose of uniting and matrimony
jorge esteban garea benjamin arthur hall
yes yes yes your love your dedication
your commitment to each other are an
example to be followed word got out to
the Archdiocese you've all known this
whole time that Ben and I have been
living together the decision is
effective immediately
now we invite you all here today because
from your family with my private lessons
and Ben's pension we need a place to
stay why are we even talking about this
I'm the only one with the extra bedroom
no it's not about that minute
Kip see I didn't have a very productive
day you know my favorite story of yours
listen neighbors again no it's your
uncle
which one is your favorite
decided that songs just turned up with a
potty bang Caban hey my friend is here
we need to work on a school presentation
and there's nowhere else for us to
that's so gay he doesn't mean the
homosexual Uncle Ben you just mean
stupid
hey have some private time please and
you're live with people you know them
better than you care to
there was a famous sip in right here in
this bar oh my god you're that guy no
it's one of the guys Wow this rounds on
me fellas
such a liar
you